from spectator.org does Jazz Jennings
regret transitioning they tried to make
Jazz the example of how amazing gender
transition is all they did was show how
bad it is I want to say a few things as
we start I genuinely and sincerely hope
Jazz finds happiness and health and
safety and
um I feel really bad for for jazz
Jennings she was lied to I think that
jazz is is the victim of very serious
parental abuse or child abuse the
parents are abusing Jazz and and I'm
going to play a video for you guys which
may make you which may you may find
disturbing however it aired on TLC and
because it airs on cable television
Nationwide I would make the argument
that YouTube has no standing to take any
issue with the video I'm going to to
play for you nothing in it is graphic
except for the statements made by Jazz
Jennings mother who threatens to I'm
just gonna say it forcefully insert a
lubricated later into the pelvic wound
of her child on cable television says
and if you don't I will ring your neck
tell me this is not child abuse and how
this is on television and then we'll
talk about the issue of jazz and I
believe Jazz Jennings desperately needs
State intervention I'm not a big status
I'm a little statist I think there
should be some I'm not I'm not an
anarchist I think the state is okay to a
little bit all right and this is one of
the instances where I think the state
needs to intervene I think jazz is an
adult at this point she's 23. but just
about 22. the state needs to take Jazz
away from these people I'm gonna play
for play uh play you this clip and and
and uh there's two of them actually
this is disturbing you've been warned
with her I'm worried about like her
mental
well-being and her dilation the minute
she leaves my house we have a dilation
problem that is a concern we don't have
that watchful eye they tend to go back
to Old patterns I have woken Jazz out of
a dead sleep and taken the dilator and
put the lubrication on it and said here
you take this and you put it in your
vagina if not I will but jazz is bad
even when I'm home once a day I will be
so mad after machine
goes away in college and that thing
seals up I will bring her neck can you
imagine
I will wring her neck if she doesn't so
the story here is that jazz Jennings is
not using a dilator for those that
aren't familiar a dilator is a tool that
trans women use to spread the wound that
is created to simulate a vagina called
the neovagina and they have to do it
forever forever to prevent the closure
of the wound when you get a slash wound
the wound attempts to close itself so
when they did surgery on Jazz to create
a uh it's a facsimile uh it's it's
I don't know how you would
scientifically describe it a a wound
with surgically grafted stomach lining
to simulate a sexual organ they call it
a Neo vagina but it's not a vaginas I
don't think that that makes sense to say
jazz is not doing this so what for
whatever reason Jazz does not want to do
this so the mother says she wakes Jazz
up in the middle of the night takes the
dilator lubricates it and says stick it
in or I will
that is horrifying and then she says if
she goes off to college and doesn't do
this and it closes up I will ring her
neck could you imagine how is that not a
threat of very serious abuse to say that
you will take that you wake up in the
middle of the night with an object you
demand be inserted into your child's
cavity and that you will choke them if
they don't do it it's monstrous it but
jazz is 22 so is it just they're just an
abusive relationship that's totally
legal and everything's it's not it's not
it look there's there's spousal abuse
there's parental abuse if a man was
waking his wife up in the middle of the
night with an object and lubricating it
and say you better stick this in or I
will do it myself that would be spousal
rape and you would go to prison for that
is it a concern that if it does seal up
that it will get infected and the Jazz
can die from sepsis or something it's
that you may have to have a surgery
again but it'll get infected and have
problems regardless like Landon said but
no the real concern is that it'll close
up and then you have to have the surgery
again and the real question that should
have been asked is hey Jazz
do you regret this surgery yeah
later it's painful there's recurring
infections and she clearly doesn't want
the successful surgery that is not
successful for surgery so here you have
a human being Jazz clearly not wanting
to do this and a mother forcing her to
do it with the threat of violence let me
play this clip for you from from the
show as well
so um are you feeling like you wanted to
start talking about
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna cry
but you know I can't get out of my yeah
I know no listen it just doesn't stop
it's okay give me a hug it's okay I know
what you're going through we've been
nervous no it still doesn't stop now and
I'm already going back to negative but
the more you're talking about yourself
it gets harder you're digging in and
you're it's making you put a magnifying
glass on what's already difficult as it
is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy oh my God that Mom's a
psycho you're Your Own Worst Enemy
you're the one doing it Jason like my
mind is very cluttered and not clear and
I really want to have that Clarity I
really want to understand myself and be
able to read my own soul and what I want
and it's just very challenging and I
think I'm kind of breaking down a little
bit and spiraling into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we've ever I don't feel like
me ever do you know that jazz Jennings
Jennings has also started dating women
yeah and that's that that should not be
shockingly I I believe Jazz Jennings is
suffering from gender dysphoria a
thousand percent and I think probably
deep down experiencing regret over the
surgeries that they've had and the
hormones they've had I don't know if
regret is the right word because
regret to me would would signify Jazz
making a decision
then later on saying I should not have
done that hence regret I think
manipulated into thinking that she made
a decision because the truth is this
looks more like Munchausen by proxy to
me where a mom has absolutely lost it
and started putting their own problems
and need for attention on their child
played it out through the child helped
push and inch them in different
directions towards something they wanted
that they knew would produce attention
and now we're continuing the cycle of
abuse to continue the attention and the
child at this point buys it and is is
also at the same time experiencing the
real emotional I know it's my fault
that's crazy the mom's saying you are
Your Own Worst Enemy yeah that's tour
that's Abu that's to get that into a
child's mind and tell them you know your
problem when you think about things you
take a magnifying glass and obsess over
it it makes the kid crazy it makes them
do that thing and he wants to get away
from this woman yes Landon said
something to me before where she has
seen this clip and she said imagine if
this was a boyfriend talking to what we
have two daughters out of our three kids
imagine if was a boyfriend talking to
one of our daughters treating her like
this saying you're Your Own Worst Enemy
and she's blaming herself there it's all
my fault I know it's all my fault you
know this is not okay in any context you
know like the the behaviors we see here
are very clearly manipulative well look
there are certain circumstances where I
would tell someone it's their fault if
if someone is getting upset I would and
there was nothing to be upset about and
I'm like okay maybe there's I typically
don't defer to chemical imbalance but I
usually tell people hey look start
exercising start eating healthy you'll
probably see your mood improve with jazz
the reason I think it's so egregious
that the mother is saying you're Your
Own Worst Enemy is that it's the mother
that did this to Jazz and jazz is saying
I don't feel like me I don't feel like
me it's because the mom is trying to
brainwash you and make you think like
her dude get out of there I wanna I
wanna say this I will take credit for
this for all of the things the left
wants to make fun of me for for getting
wrong or whatever because I get things
wrong fine I predicted all of this years
ago go what happened was when Jazz is a
child Jazz said that they were attracted
to boys
then around 13 or 14 on the TV show and
whatever that came out Jazz was now
pansexual and I said what does that mean
that means Jazz has found an attraction
to females that's the only explanation
right at the age where boys start to
have an attraction to females and then I
said when I covered this I'm willing to
bet that in a few years Jazz will be it
will be considered a trans lesbian Jazz
will want to date women because Jazz is
a male who is finding attraction to
females low we are now seeing on the
show Jazz has begun dating women
saying like there was something weird
about dating the guys and want to try
something else maybe that's the right
thing
imagine just having your parents do this
to you taking away your ability of a
family telling you it's your fault and
the things you're feeling are your fault
that's terrible all the time but but I
want to stress this the psychological
stuff you want to have an argument about
it fine you want to say no no you don't
understand she's trying to support a
trans kid okay waking your child up in
the middle of the night with a
lubricated dilator and saying stick it
in or else is the most psychotic thing
ever and that woman should be arrested
for monstrous monstrous and that exposes
the lunacy behind this entire charade
this is abuse it has always been abuse
it's why we've done what we've done to
ban it in our state I'm very proud of
the state of Tennessee and our
legislature and our governor for getting
that in into law setting a standard in
these other states who this week have
started to do the same thing I know
Georgia did there's other states we've
been working with legislators to
introduce these laws and get them passed
and I think we're going to make this the
norm in every red State we're going to
make sure every red state gets these
laws on the books and prevents these
situations so that we don't see more
Jazz Jennings situations in the future
and instead we see healthy kids who got
talk therapy and we're then able to
reverse the gender dysphoria and be in
love with the person that they were born
to be the natural person that God
created and that's why Landon does her
organization freedom forever because we
need people fighting for these kids so
we have this real quick um from
soapdirt.com I'm not super familiar but
while spectator.org does briefly mention
that jazz Jennings went on a date with a
woman this article actually goes into
detail in February about jazz Jenning
wanting to date women and uh talking
about going speed dating and having
troubles and then finding a connection
with women surprise surprise the
biological male of which 98 find
connections with women has found a
connection with women
so my my view on this was
if you have a kid and you think that kid
is trans well you get about a 98 chance
that kid is not 99. you know nine seven
chance the kid is not is that a bet you
want to make on putting the kid through
irreversible surgeries and hormone
Therapies in the event this kid is now
20 years old crying depressed morbidly
obese binge eating Jazz was supposed to
go to school college a long time ago and
did not because of severe depression
right what I think my view not a
psychologist psychiatrist no idea I
think Jazz has these feelings inside but
knows because of the TV show because of
the book because of Jazz's family they
can never come out and say it just like
a young gay man is scared to come out
and tell his family that he's gay
because of what Society demands of him
because of what his he expects he thinks
his family expects of him Jazz doesn't
want to come out as
detransitioner or or straight mail her
entire identity has been built upon this
you know and that's the whole reason
that she is so depressed she's never
been given proper health care that
that is that you're born in the wrong
body imagine like just the the the
trauma that causes a child to be told
something's wrong with you you were born
in the wrong body you know that that
sets up a child on a lifetime dependency
of external validation so she's talking
about her soul clearly she's searching
for an identity and meaning Beyond The
Superficial identity the the woke you
know gender identity your sexuality
they're gonna say oh just experiment
with your sexuality experiment with your
gender and and have surgeries and get on
the blockers all of these things and
that path just is a path to
self-destruction lifelong dependency and
big Pharma gaping wound in her you know
Neo vagina which she'll never be a real
functioning vagina
um this is medical exploitation that's
the proper term for what is happening to
these children there is only one reason
to perform a penile inversion
vaginoplasty on a minor Jazz was 17
years old when this surgery was
performed it is to create a wound that a
male can insert his penis into for
sexual pleasure that's it that's it's
jazz jazz cannot uh feel uh any pleasure
based on the hormone blocker treatments
that is a statement made by the Doctor
Who treated jez that they need to slow
down on what they're doing because these
young males who undergo these treatments
lose sexual function and feeling right
yeah mental abuse so Jazz one of the
reasons Jess probably does not want to
dilate at all is because it serves no
legitimate function for Jess's life
other than to let a man have sex with
the wound and feminists are standing up
for this the left-wing feminists are
standing up for this where we're going
to make somebody do this for the
pleasure of of men for a man and let
that man also pretend to be one of us
and pretend that this should be a normal
thing for women to do this because I
mean it's crazy this grafted wound will
provide no pleasure for a woman nothing
in fact Four Women
isn't this whole idea of creating a
vagina out of a penis kind of I mean
I've never actually asked you isn't it
offensive absolutely everything about
this is about the Erasure of women my my
Womanhood is not a construct we are a
class of people and everything from the
woman face that's happening to the
Erasure of our actual you know identity
and and calling assist people birthing
persons breasts or chest feeders is so
incredibly demeaning
um so it absolutely like it's an assault
on Womanhood as well but I was just
thinking about you know the puberty
blocker is something that doesn't get
talked about enough the the chemical
castration what do you think a boy would
choose to do if their penis shrivels up
because that's what happens when you get
put on puberty blockers as a male if you
have no penis that does not grow from
puberty you're going to opt to cut it
off because you're working with nothing
in some cases can't even get an erection
the rest of your life let alone have an
orgasm or any of these things so they're
already castrating them but these kids
don't don't know anything they don't
know if look if if this if a person was
an adult and said you know I'd like to
undergo something I'd be like well okay
you're an adult fine whatever however
there's still considerations we made
like if someone came to me who's 30
years old and said I want my hand
removed we probably say no to that right
but these children here's here's the
thing I see about jazz Jennings the
reason I said I think jazz is suffering
from gender dysphoria is because Jazz is
a male in a pseudo-female body and
probably wants to be male hence gender
dysphoria Jazz as a small child was
never a man
Jazz was always just a previewescent boy
who underwent surgery and hormone
therapies to become the facsimile of a
woman and prevent male development
so there's no point at which Jazz could
truly know what it is to be a man and
want to be a woman
they they're they're doing this thing
where they're taking a child and saying
look at a woman look at a man which one
do you want to be and I guess that one
it's like okay we'll get the surgery
ready well then sure enough Jazz reaches
a uh the adult age and something goes
terribly wrong yeah
oh that's that's the overthinking Jazz
this comes from your mind being too
smart it's just your environment your
mom has been way too pushy like just
free your mind babe what do you think
happens when imgs gets canceled
oh I think she will absolutely start to
explore the truth so I think what you
said about I think so is absolutely true
that the whole reason she is not
expressed feelings that I'm I feel like
this is again my opinion I feel like
the same thing that you're feeling like
that she regret or Jazz regrets this and
is starting to look at I made a big
mistake in my life I actually do feel
like a male and is questioning what to
do my thought is is that when this all
comes crashing down they are going to
turn around and start to call out the
abusers and the people that lied to them
because I'll give you an example Chris
Beck do you are you guys familiar with
Chris Beck he's a Navy SEAL served 13
tours overseas became the first uh
special operator who came out as trans
did a whole special on CNN he then came
out on my podcast as de-transitioning
many years later and this just happened
this year story went crazy and uh Chris
you know I I talked to him a lot about
this and essentially you know the the
book deal and the book being out there
and the coverage and everything made it
very difficult to turn around and it was
bravery that made him turn around and
tell the truth about what happened and
how the military was really just out of
control with this whole thing I mean
when if you hear the whole story it's
insane I mean it was first appointment
within 20 minutes he was given hormones
okay a doctor that worked with the
government convinced him to write a book
to make money on being transgender to
help normalize transgenderism
and the media helped sell it to sell the
idea that even the most masculine men
can question their gender and become
women you know and it all worked I mean
this laid the groundwork for where we
are now and now that very person they
used for propaganda is now today the
person standing up saying do not let
this happen to children I needed to
speak up because this is torture what
this did these kids don't deserve it and
doing it from a place of love you know
he's speaking up because he doesn't want
anybody to get hurt yeah I'm thinking
about if someone made a YouTube channel
about cutting your hand off and they cut
their hand off and they're like kids you
can do it too if you you don't you
probably feel like you don't have a hand
already that's okay just cut it like
that person I would consider danger to
society and I would want them at least
taken off TV not because I hate them
because I want to protect the kid yeah
and what about school teachers doing it
saying remember don't tell your parents
you want you want to remove your hands
we will go to your doctor and we will
get your hand chopped off but don't tell
your parents speaking of prison I mean
they don't just want to normalize this
they actually want to take children from
parents who refuse to use the pronouns
affirm their you know delusions from
from the parents State kidnapping that's
that's already happening we already have
bills in Minnesota right now to you know
have the state kidnapping done if you do
not affirm a child your child can be
taken from you in the United States of
America that's where we're at what did
you guys do in Tennessee is you passed
got a bill passed but what exactly does
the bill lay out what got changed you
have to wait till 18 to get any of these
surgeries to get the hormones to get the
puberty blockers we're not going to stop
the natural development of a child in
the state of Tennessee we're not going
to go and mutilate their bodies with
hormones puberty blockers or these
surgeries these kids are innocent
children of God whether they believe in
it or not even if you don't believe in
that you're an innocent child we are not
going to allow them to be mutilated in
our state and that's what we put in the
code is that's not going to happen
anymore in the state of Tennessee you're
going to have to wait till you're an
adult to make these decisions I mean
personally disagree with it at that
point and think that it is unwise and
Eileen more in Tim's territory honestly
where I see it the same way as somebody
asking to chop their arm off and I think
it's unethical and it should be
something that's banned in medical
practices and I think honestly we
shouldn't go that far well I'm going
further I think it really should end up
there personally but I understand the
Nuance of Law and where we have to be at
and the ability to you know have these
laws stand the test of time and I think
that that's a barometer that everybody
can live with that you have to wait till
you're an adult to do this I do however
think that perhaps it's time to start
having that conversation about just not
allowing transgender surgeries at all or
or treatments uh the reason being like I
said if someone comes to you and says
that they want to remove a body part we
typically say no you can't do that but
there is only one dysmorphic disorder
that results in affirmation and it's
transgenderism I mean there there are
issues of people getting what tons of
surgeries that's why I'm not at that
point where I would advocate for
outright Banning it for all ages because
there are people who get lip splits and
tongue splits and I'm like well if
you're an adult man so I I suppose
they're real there really is a deep
challenge yeah on the legal front I
understand we win as far as I think you
can go which is saying wait till an
adult on a moral front I morally feel
like
people have a duty and responsibility to
not participate in this because it's the
abusive of human beings and and frankly
we're talking about human beings who
have very serious problems in the true
empathetic thing to do is deal with the
trauma not cut appendage off you know
not cut their genitalia not drug them
you know and if we're not dealing with
the actual problem and an adult can go
into one of these hormone offices and
say
I think this will fix my problems and a
doctor just says yep here you go here's
your here's your life changing not in a
good way adding side effects drugs that
are not even labeled for this purpose
they're not even meant for this purpose
okay what drugs the puberty blocks which
are not even meant for this and lupron's
not meant for this even even the uh the
actual testosterone and estrogen in many
cases have not been tested for long
periods of time for this use of
transitioning somebody from a biological
state of being a biological male to a
woman over a long period of time to do
this in a double-blind way that's not
looking at some sort of you know what
they love to do as convenient sampling
for people who've never heard of this
this is where you put together a group
of people on purpose who you know are
going to affirm the desired result you
want this happens all the time in this
area of medicine so if there's anybody
who's confused and they're thinking
about this look at everything across the
board and look out for convenience
sampling where they lie I I was
wondering where this synthetic
testosterone comes from do you know
where synthetic testosterone comes from
bull testicles no oh I was actually why
did we both think one way to go how is
where rose petals good guess what do you
think how do they how do they get it how
do they synthesize testosterone
from from what
no guess from a nut
it is often derived from plant sources
such as soy
that's okay it says yams or soy yeah
this is from your Wellness center.com it
says uh testosterone that synthesized in
a medical laboratory often from plant
sources such as yams or soy is
engineered to match the same exact
chemical structure that is already being
produced Naturally by your body this
enables it to perfectly mimic the
original source
how about that wow I didn't know that I
thought it was like horses or something
yeah
soy is known for its estrogen content or
at least you can isolate anything I
guess that's wild I wonder where the
majority of Peabody blockers are made if
they're made here or China because I
know a lot of our Pharmaceuticals have
you have you ever heard the story of the
the radon girls I think it was called no
do you want you want to look that up
real quick I think was called the radon
girls I was gonna add by the way what
you said about Tick Tock so Landon and I
are actually going to uh radio tomorrow
Tick Tock rally in DC with a bunch of
members of Congress and and the reason
why is this is not just an app this is a
weapon not in China
the radium girls were working in watch
factories and they were taking radium
paint that could make watches glow and
it was this hot thing at the turn of the
century early 1900s and so you'd have a
watch that would glow in the dark but
the radium was very radioactive these
women would paint their teeth with it so
when you turn the lights off and smile
you'd see their glowing teeth and then
within a few years their jaws would
swell up with cancer their mouths would
fall off literally their mouths would
break and fall off their jaw would fall
off their teeth would fall into their
mouths their heads would enlarge I think
about stuff like that and then I think
about jazz Jennings except I'm I was
looking at that that video thumbnail and
I'm like
radium girls
was it dothalidomide Jesus asbestos
lobotomies wow I think in a hundred
years they're gonna look back and be
like how barbaric these people were
barbarians they used to drink they used
to drink Mercury to try and cure
syphilis the idea was the Mercury would
kill enough of your body that the
syphilis would die off and then you'd
you'd slowly try and come back from it
that's key a lot of chemotherapy does
that we're going to kill the Cancer and
a bunch of stuff along with it yeah well
why don't you try and heal the body
instead well I mean because if we don't
know how to do it the best we can is
that I guess but the issue is jazz
Jennings I don't believe was ever a
human being who went to a doctor saying
I am distressed I'm the wrong gender
Jazz was three years old when when their
parents said you're actually a girl and
jazzed K and jazz is brilliant and
intellectually smart person I can you
can tell by listening to her for like 10
seconds that she's got a brilliant mind
that's all over the place unfocused and
unfortunately a mother that's like
provoking pain within her it seems like
I'm blaming you Mom you did this to her
sick and you know what for the record if
if anybody you know hears this or gives
this message to her Freedom Forever will
help her if she wants that care we want
to be a Lifeline for her because I don't
know if anybody's offered that but we
will provide resources for survivors of
medical exploitation of this gender
ideology Freedom Forever what is it
freedomforever.us that's my non-profit
combating all forms of child
exploitation so if she wants help we are
here for her whenever she needs it but
how would she contact you um she can go
to the website freedomforever.us or you
know people can at her and say you know
contact this or if you ever need help we
will help you think about this though
there was a there was a post in 2016
that was someone took a post a coming
out story what it was like coming out to
their parents as gay and they changed
gay to Trump supporter and it was funny
because a bunch of Trump's voters are
like wow that's hilarious it was it was
because it was saying kind of generic
things like I'm worried what my parents
will think if they find out that I'm
insert voting for Trump my parents are
really against this there they watch the
news all the time and their views are
very much blah blah and you know my
friends will will be mad at me and I'm
worried what people think I thought that
was funny I want you to imagine what
would be like Robbie if you came out
tomorrow with an antifa shirt on and
just said I have been lying I am anti
for 100 what would your friends say what
would your colleagues say you know that
it would be very stressful for you right
they would say
um honestly I think they would all laugh
and be like come on Robbie nobody
believes that but like but like like if
you came out and seriously told all of
your closest friends and family that
some something they believed to be true
was no longer true yeah if Jazz were to
come out on TV
to family and friends and sponsors
I'm a guy this was a mistake
that would completely destroy everything
Jazz has I think it would destroy this
whole thing that's going on right now
okay okay yes yes but my point is just
that jazz will not do it she might she
might the jazz is brave enough to do it
and be the person that they were born to
be and to embrace it and to let people
love you back to life because here's the
thing
sometimes I do think people on our side
can be guilty of reacting really harshly
to some of these people as they get
older and it's because we start to
forget these were people who were abused
as children and in many cases have
sexual traumas from being raped and we
do have to have some form of empathy to
the trauma that these people have
experienced and with somebody like jazz
some people are mad because they say
well Jazz helped normalize this whole
thing and it's hurt other people well I
blame her parents for that frankly and
the doctors who lied and acted
unethically well this is somebody who
was abused as a child and is now an
adult and if we open our arms and say
hey we're willing to love you back to
life for the person that you actually
were born to be maybe maybe it won't be
Jazz but somebody will Embrace us Jazz's
doctor has come out saying it was wrong
yep so Jazz's doctor is not the person
who lied she has the Jazz's doctor is
the person who screwed up and then came
out and said holy crap this was a
mistake well I watched the doctor lie I
watched previous episodes like all the
way through I watched doctor live from
when they sold the idea of surgery okay
to the reality of surgery and what
happened and making it sound like it
would solve everything and make things
better and then later seeing what we all
see now with jazz clearly four surgeries
later side effects later damage later in
fact Jazz at one point said she wouldn't
even look at what happened after the
surgeries initially because it was so
horrific
they didn't want her to look wow and
Jazz when Jazz ended up when Jazz ended
up taking a peek
she said it was horrifying and I keep
saying I'm only saying because Jazz is a
female name it's like my by uh you know
just that natural order of things you
want to say she but we all know this is
a biological male and that's
indisputable and these differences occur
for a reason and we've got to embrace
our differences and get somebody like
jazz to love themselves back to life
there are virtually no resources
available for D transitioners not
medically not Mental Health Care unless
they do digging or find organizations
like ours that's the problem every
single transitioner I've spoken with
their surgeons won't solve their
unresolved issues they don't want to
touch them they will not help you know
deal with the issues all the aftermath
left behind so there's a real mental
health and you know physical health Gap
in what these detransitioners are
experiencing and I would say the
majority of the ones that I've spoken to
and work with have sexual trauma in in
the in the genderqueer book we have to
bring up because you know Ian bought it
and it was very smart of him to do so as
much as I don't want this individual to
get money from this have you ever read
it oh yes we exposed it years ago and so
what we've talked about in the show is
many conservative commentators who
reference it never actually read it they
don't know it's a story about a little
girl who was abused by her parents who
was peeing in the yard who couldn't read
till 12 and would wear crusted dirty
pads that smelled so bad the school
counselor had to give her a talking to
like you need to clean your body that's
child abuse it's also a sign of
trafficking and exploitation and it
results in a person who's deeply
confused and traumatized jazz is very
much the same yes how we save these
people from this abuse is is you know I
don't know because we used to have a
system we created the system Child
Protective Services to be like do not
they're not doing it no no they're doing
the opposite yeah you know someone super
chatted if you if you if a kid
threatened to hurt themselves and you
brought them to the to the doctor they
would enforce the the the
um surgeries they're enforcers now
they're they're they're absolute
enforcers for the ideology they will
literally report the parents to CPS to
have the parents removed from the home
if the parents are even questioning this
in a way that they feel is not affirming
but not they're part of the system here
they they they're the people profiting
off this but they're profiting off the
surgeries and the hormones right one of
the uh organizations that we work with
has one case of a girl named Sage who
was trafficked not once but twice
through CPS after being forcefully put
into State care because her caretakers
her family would not affirm her
transitioning okay so that's what we're
dealing with that that's what happens
when you don't affirm your child that's
what they're trying to normalize they're
not just saying hey let's be taller
they're literally trying to steal
children and use our government you know
CPS systems to facilitate this I think
we have to have like a a bigger
conversation as as a country about CPS
at some point too because this is
separate from this but what's going on
in a lot of states with CPS is Criminal
when you see the types of situations
they're stealing kids and creating
lifelong emotional trauma by taking them
from their parents over ridiculous
things it's really scary it's scary when
you hear these stories you know just a
case happened actually in Tennessee that
I'm trying to help these people they
don't even live in Tennessee they're
from Georgia the dad got pulled over had
a little bit of weed and initially the
police told the mom she could take the
kids drive them back home but she's like
well I live in Georgia I'm going to have
to go bail my husband out first she goes
to the the police station to do it and
there they end up calling CPS they take
the kids from her and they end up
mandating a drug test on her
and so they don't even have the results
of that but they take the children and
even if it was marijuana we're talking
about somebody that could have done
marijuana previously weeks earlier in
Georgia and still had it in a follicle
test or something and you're saying
that's good police work to steal these
children create lifelong traumas and
possibly place them with a dangerous
person
when they're in no danger they didn't
George Floyd didn't George Floyd have
kids in the back when he was on an eight
ball what happened to those kids it was
him his mother a friend and oh okay no
he's not some guy anyway I don't want to
deflect I think you're saying Jacob
Blake thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time